[Musique]
elle est devenu député de la martinique
élu dans la circonscription nord très
officiellement le 24 avril dernier
manuela qui est clairement des zirides
ensemble a dit ce matin
bonjour madame la députée bonjour
messieurs y ait un jour un atout c'est
qu'ils nous écoutent
merci d'être avec nous ce siège que vous
occupez aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale on le rappelle est liée au
retour de bruno nestor azérot en mairie
de sainte-marie aussi par cette loi sur
le non cumul des mandats on vous
attendait depuis janvier avec cette
écharpe de parlementaire et comment avez
vous vécu cette longue attente
alors c'est vrai que l'atteinte de plus
un peu plus de deux mois et paris c'est
long mais j'ai optimiser ce temps
optimiser ce temps en rencontrant de
nombreuses associations des médias des
institutions est d'ailleurs beaucoup ont
demandé des rendez vous donc jamais
vraiment au chaud dans la peau de la
suppléante
oui toujours dans la peau de la
suppléante mais c'est vrai qu'il était
prévu un déjà qu'on qu'on fonctionne
ainsi un conte fonctionnent en binôme
il n'était pas prévu que tout de suite
après les élections que bruno et moi on
se sait pas que chacun fasse son son
accompli ses missions mais vraiment un
travail d'équipé
donc j'avais déjà client on va dire à
bras le corps le vrai rôle d'une
suppléante qui est dix fois la même
chose
darko la même chose que de porte le
costume de député mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui et ben je pourrais porter
moi même
on va dire les données en c1 défendre
les intérêts des martyrs justement vous
êtes là sous la terre ce matin avec nous
pour nous dire comment vous percevez 7,7
fonctions sept
cette fonction de parlementaire alors je
perçois vraiment comme un engagement un
engagement encore plus fort puisque ma
vie politique était déjà bien au radiant
j'étais déjà bien active à la vie
politique ça fait 16 ans que je suis
engagé en politique je le rappelle où
j'ai été quand je reçois ce joseph
conseillère régionale j'ai été et
aujourd'hui adjointe au maire à la ville
de saint-joseph donc la vie politique
mon action politique mon engagement
politique était déjà bien inscrit
maintenant c'est un autre niveau
c'est une autre manière pression mais
que je prends avec beaucoup de sauts
vraiment parler de deux niveaux
lorsqu'on est député par rapport à cette
fonction d'élu très locale que
représente une municipalité
alors quand je parle de niveau je dirais
ce niveau de d'échangés de lieu pour
défendre des intérêts c'est vrai que
être à l'assemblée nationale être
conseillère municipale c'est pas du tout
les mêmes chances et pas les mêmes on va
dire les mêmes compétences et même
niveau de d'engagement qui sont imposés
d'ailleurs nous sommes complémentaires
c'est pour ça qu'il ya plusieurs
manières plusieurs je reviens sur le sur
le niveau ya plusieurs fonctions en
politique mais qui doit être
complémentaire bagneux l'aqpa ronde et
vous connaissez ce qui mine la vie des
martiniquais on l'a vu les sargasses
véritable poison
le transport à l'arrêt et des grèves
sans moment à n'importe quelle heure de
prix du billet d'avion la sécurité
routière le chômage et cette rengaine du
peuple coincé entre désillusions
désespoir c'est lui a pas qu'à fait ier
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cela alors
c'est vrai que c'était c'est un
raccourci c'est vrai que c'est un
ressenti à il faut l'entendre à la
population
ressent et le vit chaque jour c'est vrai
maintenant je dis qu'il faut toujours
garder espoir et puis nous avons une
évolution nous avons des évolutions qui
qui sont prévus et je pense que un
renouvellement aussi de dire de la
classe politique d'en donner moi
messieurs mesdames mais un
renouvellement de la classe politique
s'impose et malheureusement je je je
crains que aujourd'hui le regard qu'on a
sur la sur la vie politique aujourd'hui
et freine et désengage la population et
tous ceux d'ailleurs qui pourrait venir
s'engager en politique alors au
contraire je je je dis ben leur est il
est temps il est temps que chacun puisse
s'engager et qu'on apporte une autre
façon de faire la politique aujourd'hui
vous êtes persuadé qu'il est possible de
faire plus
et comment est ce qu'une approche
féminine peut booster l'action politique
en compagnie de josette manin l'autre
député et catherine conconne la
sénatrice est ce qu'il y aura une
une roumaine connection ici en
martinique alors je l'espère et je crois
que quatre kinés et josette l'on engagé
déjà nous sentons bien que il ya une
autre manière d'aborder ne serait-ce que
relationnellement ne serait ce que sur
les méthodes nous avons d'autres
méthodes et je crois que là ça va
effectivement apporter un plus et
booster autrement maintenant au doublage
politique alors maintenant c'est ce que
j'allais dire il faut vraiment que nous
soyons unis et que nos sessions
justement ces querelles qui finalement
ne servent pas la population entre le
nous servir le grosse tarte à la crème
au delà des clivages au delà des clans
politiques
oui mais pour l'instant dans le concret
alors je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut
vraiment que nous ayons confiance en
nous et que nous ayons confiance en
cette nouvelle dynamique qu'il que nous
sommes capables de
d'impulser et je crois et j'ai vraiment
confiance à catherine et un josette pour
que ensemble nous puissions
effectivement discuté et puis
changer nos méthodes nous parler de
josette de catherine est ce que maurice
antiste l'autre sénateur reid accord est
ce que jean philippe ni l'or l'autre
député est-ce qu'il est d'accord
également devoir d'accepter ce regard
disons féminin sur la conception qu'il
faudrait avoir de la politique je crois
pas j'ai pas on n'a pas ressenti un pour
ce que nous avons déjà eu des échanges
serge et de chimie maurice antilles
c'est évidemment naylor il ya vraiment
pas d'animosité il ya vraiment pas de de
difficultés à échanger à discuter
maintenant nous asseoir autour de la
notion de manquement cette habitude de
travailler ensemble et je crois que il
écrit nous pouvons pas faire votre look
et surtout quand on écoute chacun
d'entre eux individuellement ils sont
tous d'accord pour qu'on puisse faire
front face aux difficultés aujourd'hui
qui s'imposent à nous donc je pense que
peut-être que je ferai le lien et je le
souhaite vraiment parce que j'ai
toujours eu de très bonnes relations
avec tous ces hommes et je pense que il
est possible il est possible aujourd'hui
de 2 d'autres les autres départements
appelle aussi à ce que nous soyons tous
on va dire les les dom réunis autour des
problématiques qui nous concerne tout le
monde se veut au dessus des clivages
politiques tout le monde veut des
réunions travail des projets menés au
delà de l'appartenance un clan à bord et
quelle devrait être la place la de
l'idéologie aujourd'hui alors l'île de
logis elle se construit elle se poursuit
dans nos partis dans nos mouvements
politiques
nous sommes entrés en politique chacun
nous sommes entrés en politique avec une
idéologie nous rognons pas cette
idéologie
maintenant nous sommes tous nous avons
tous un point commun qui est la
martinique et à la population qui vote
pour une biologiste
oui c'est une idéologie money money nous
on idéologie c'est de faire en sorte que
socialement qu'économiquement que la
martinique se sentent bien voulu le
travail que vous avez à faire là oui je
sais mais rodgers métis volant j'avais
l'impression que la martinique va bien
alors la martinique c'est vrai qu'elle
est elle est en souffrance
avant le voyant il faut pas le nier nous
avons une attente très importante et
nous avons aussi un problème sur le
média l'économie du pays les entreprises
que j'ai rencontré effectivement s'offre
ce qui me peine aujourd'hui qui
m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est le niveau
de consommation des fonds européens
et cela c'est vrai que c'est du fait de
la citer m
mais il faut effectivement que nous que
nous allions vers des échanges avec avec
la collectivité territoriale de martini
qui qui et qui aujourd'hui ingérence de
ces fonds mais la situation économique
et et est grande
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise des chefs
d'entreprise que vous rencontrez puisque
vous avez pu discuter avec eux pendant
du mois voir d'autres en fonction
officiellement le 24 avril dernier le
rappelle ils vous disent quoi les chefs
d'entreprise alors la difficulté
aujourd'hui est que beaucoup
d'entreprises atteint énormément le
versement des fonds européens l'art ne
serait ce que la la prise en compte de
leurs demandes et ils ont investi et
aujourd'hui ils attendent en retour que
le que leur dossier soit accepté
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une difficulté et
on va dire
un goulot d'étranglement au niveau du
traitement de ces dossiers
c'est votre boulot à vous en tant que
député manuel qui est en mon désir de
faire le trait d'union entre ses chefs
d'entreprise et la septième pour leur
dire alors ce n'est pas le jeu c'est pas
un travail fondamental effectivement dû
d'un parlementaire mais je crois que
quand on est faut pas rester détaché
quand on est parlementaire on est je
suis dépité mais c'est pas pour cela que
je dois fermer les yeux sur ce qui se
passera dans mon pays
au contraire c'est le terrain qui
nourrit qu'innover l'action et c'est
vrai que au delà de l' échange et on va
dire du 2 du rôle d'intermédiaire que je
pourrais avoir avec les élus de la
martinique qui a aussi
on va dire une proposition que je suis
en train de travailler pour que
justement nous ayons comme la réunion
d'ailleurs a réussi à l'avoir une forme
d'avancés
sur les fonds européens pour les
entreprises martiniquaises
alors c'est une négociation qui se
ferait qu il se fera à brusque à
bruxelles
mais c'est là justement il faut que les
parlementaires avec nos réseaux au
niveau du gouvernement et au niveau de
l'assemblée a failli elle que nous
devons mettre mes draps en actions pour
que justement cette cette proposition
puisse être atteint en 2000 il nous
reste quelques secondes manulife du kram
on désire vous avez remplacé goudeau
nestor azérot nous l'avons entendu la
septième en 2021 salle intéresse
fortement
on sait aussi que j'ai tout petit regard
très intéressés du côté de la présidence
de cap nord vous et l'accompagner sur
quelle bataille alors moi jacques open
j'accompagnerai bruno sur toutes les
batailles nous sommes aujourd'hui
associés nous sommes aujourd'hui dans
une démarche et je voulais 10,1 nous
voulons vraiment offrir une nouvelle
offre politique à la martinique et je
crois que ça passe par les batailles
politiques dites moi il serait beaucoup
plus ctm ou cap non mais je pense que
devriez vraiment l'invité de bataille
avec lui oui non nous serons présents
nous saurons vraiment présent ce sera
pas lui ce sera pas moi seulement mais
nous serons ensemble avec on va dire une
organisation que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place et il nous irons à la
bataille là c'était un jeu quelque chose
nous irons aussi un jus que nous ne
soyons pas sur les ssig nous avons bien
vu que les sigles ne porte pas forcément
chose mais nous allons vraiment dans une
démarche il faut vraiment entendre la
démarche qui est pas forcément de
regrouper des parties des mouvements
politiques puisque chacun a des intérêts
politiques maintenant 1
la société civile doit être partie
prenante merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nos manuels acquittera mondésir député
de la martinique bonne journée
[Musique]